and I think that they are trying to do a
deal to move CNN and I think it's going
to be to CBS and let me tell you why
this is they call him zaz but this is
David zazov who is the
um CEO of uh Warner Brothers Discovery
and they have had what could only be
described as the year from hell with one
of their uh one of their properties CNN
so I think Disney ABC ESPN got their
hand full and frankly you know ESPN's
been bleeding subscribers and now
they've been bleeding Talent
um but here you have CBS it really
doesn't have you know additional plays
in what would be the Ott what you and I
might call Cable space CNN under CBS as
a a rejuvenated play I think makes a lot
of sense